wo ist das grab von nofretete noch immer
ist es nicht gefunden worden
doch vor kurzem gab es einen sehr
spannenden hinweis in der grabkammer von
tutanchamun da gab es seltsame echos und
aus dem antiken ministerium hieß es 2015
dass man sich zu 90 prozent sicher sein
dass dort neue kammern zu finden sein
das grab von tutanchamun stiefmutter
nofretete jetzt wurde es genauer
untersucht jede ergebnisse weg zum
science and fiction herzlich willkommen
schon seit 3400 jahren ist der pharao
tutanchamun tod und unter der erde
vergraben seiner grabstätte wurde 1922
entdeckt und obwohl das schon lange her
ist ist das tal der könige immer mal
wieder eine schlagzeile wert zuletzt
noch im sommer 2015 als ein britische
archäologe verkündete dass es hinter
einer grab des pharaos weitere räume
gelbe linien strukturen nahm als
hinweise und auf den aufnahmen der
nördlichen und westlichen kalkstein wand
der grabkammer wollte er vermehrte
durchgängiger erkannt haben und nicole
suisse setzte damals noch einen drauf
denn in diesen wänden sei wohl die mumie
von tutanchamuns stiefmutter nofretete
zu finden nicht wenige witterten eine
sensation es gab pressekonferenzen ohne
ende
zusätzliche bodenuntersuchung eines
radars spezialisten aus japan machten
weitere hoffnung denn auch seine
messungen ergaben wohl hinweise darauf
dass möglicherweise zwei weitere
unbekannte räume existieren könnten
langwierige und aufwendige
radarmessungen eines forschungsteams im
auftrag von national geographic sollten
dann den endgültigen beweis liefern
doch der blieb aus und das obwohl über
stunden hinweg 50 einzel scans gemacht
worden waren
und das in zwei verschiedenen frequenzen
doch das scannen im tal der könige
schien sogar der sensation zu
widersprechen dass damaligen
forschungsteam war sich am ende sicher
unentdeckte kann man also hohlräume
müssten eine starke reflexion liefern
und die blieb aus ein italienisches
forschungsteam von der universität turin
hat dann wohl anomalien an grenzen an
das fahren grab gefunden und zwar zwei
stück links und rechts von tutanchamuns
grabkammer das hätten drohnen bilder
gezeigt mit der sie die grabstätte
gescannt hatten
darauf sei eine sowohl links als auch
rechts von der grabkammer eine rote
fläche zu sehen links etwas größer als
recht auch die fläche unmittelbar neben
der grabkammer weise anomalien auf so
der ehemalige antiken minister ägyptens
mando damit zitat wir können leider noch
nicht sagen was diese anomalien bedeuten
auf die frage ob es sich vielleicht
tatsächlich um die grabkammer von
königin nofretete handelt
sagt er nur weiter wir sind
wissenschaftler und keine spekulanten ja
weitere untersuchungen bräuchten zeit
und könnten dann gewissheit geben doch
sei der begriff der anomalie ja dahinter
lässt tatsächlich ein großes
fragezeichen denn damit könnte
theoretisch gesehen natürlich alles oder
nichts gemeinsam einen hohlraum ein loch
oder doch eine unbekannte kammer bislang
sind diese ergebnisse des italienischen
forschungsteams jedenfalls noch nicht in
einem wissenschaftlichen fachjournal zu
wenden jetzt hat das team nachgelegt und
die kammer weiter untersucht ja und das
ergebnis ja das ist leider nicht
sensationell die polin untersuchungen
schließen weitere grabkammern aus drei
monate das team die grabkammern
durchleuchtet und ist auf nichts
gestoßen zitat die hypothese
hinsichtlich der existenz verborgenen
kann man oder korridore die sich an
tutanchamuns grab anschließen wird durch
die gpa daten nicht gestützt so steht es
im ägyptischen nachrichtenportal aram
online zu lesen dass aus dem
abschlussbericht von francesco porcelli
von der polytechnischen universität
turin zitiert mit drei scan durchgänge
wurden die ergebnisse jeweils überprüft
es gibt also keinen zweifel mehr die
neueren untersuchungen mittels
bodenradar gba waren nach den ersten
untersuchungen geplant worden um hier
eigentlich den fund zu bestätigen sie
geht also weiter die suche nach dem grab
von nofretete wenn er als erstes neues
dazu zu allen anderen themen erfahren
wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
hierbei whatsapp oder den anderen
messaging wie instagram facebook oder
telegramm dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion von pixel
mitmachen und mitbestimmen was hier
wirklich passiert und zur begrüßung gibt
es noch ein kleines goodie einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der stimmungslage vergessen hier
geht es war damit auch dafür braucht die
geheime kammer der jobs pyramide
entdeckt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran